Merhaba ismim Yonca Erdener ben kısaca
kendimi tanıtmak istiyorum yazar
kimliğimin dışında Öncelikle Ortadoğu
Teknik Üniversitesi Mimarlık Fakültesi
şehir planlama bölümü mezunuyum
arkasından University kalıcı lond
bastırma derecemi de gene Ortadoğu
Teknik Üniversitesi Mimarlık
fakültesinde aldım
çok uzun yıllar perakende sektöründe
çalıştım Bu özür diliyorum nasıl
ilerliyor
perakende sektöründe çalıştım hem
Mağazacılık kısmında hem e-ticaret
kısmında Amerika'da yazılmış perakende
ve dağıtım zincirleri üzerine ve dağıtım
sistemlerinin üzerine yazılmış
makalelerim var
e ticaret dijital pazarlama ve perakende
dersleri de verdim
60'a yakın ülkeye seyahat ettim
Arkeoloji ve merakım var bisiklete
biniyorum İki çocuğum var konu personel
olunca
Dolayısıyla topluma yansıttığım
kimliklerim kısaca Bunlar ve son 10
yıldır da tarihi macera türünde Romanlar
yazıyorum
Göbeklitepe muhafaza türkiye’de
Göbeklitepe ile ilgili yazılmış ilk
roman İngilizcesi de basıldı ardından 7
uyananlar romanı geldi ve çok yeni çıkan
İstanbul'un hayaletleri de yine bir
tarihi macera ve İstanbul'un
denizlerinde geçiyor
Ben pazarlama alanında çalışırken
personel ile tanışmıştım yani parsona
kavramını konuşmamı istendiğinde ben bu
kavramla ilk tanıştığım anı sizi
götürmek istiyorum O da bizim
tüketicilerimizin tanımladığımız
sınıfladığımız bir çalışmaydı personel
ile ne yapıyorduk Biz tüketicileri
temsili olarak gruplara ayırıyorduk bu
slayt benim olduğu gibi o günkü
çalışmamdan kopyalandı hiçbir
şeyin bir anne bebek ve çocuklara
yönelik satış yapan siteye de biz de
Berna diye bir temsili kişilik personel
yaratmıştık işte Berna üniversite mezunu
orta gelir üstü iyi bir semtte oturuyor
ve çalışan bir anne onu da bir çevresini
yarattık başka bir personaydı Ayşe diye
uydurmuştuk işte lise mezunu
Denizli'de yaşıyor tatillere Türkiye'de
geçiriyor gibi bu personel olarak
çerçevesinde de hem iletişim dilimize
hem kampanyalarımızı hem satış
stratejimizi belirliyorduk neden mesela
çalışan anneler e-ticaret sitelerine
öğlen arası 12 ile 1 arası
girebiliyorlardı ama yeni bebek sahibi
aileler gece yarısı emzirmeye
kalktığında tek elinde bebek sol elimde
cep telefonundan alışveriş yapıyorlardı
onun için de mesela web sitesinden değil
şefler cep telefonlarına uyumlu
kampanyalar yapıyorduk gibi ben de
dediğim gibi personele o zaman tanıyıp
kullanmıştım ama esas gerçek anlamda
personanın ne olduğunu ben 7 uyananlar
romanına yaz
7 uyananlar Tarsus'ta geçiyor işte
bilinçaltına mağara dalışlarına yug'a
çok fazla atsa olan bir kitap arka
tipleri anlatıyor hatta Yumru rüyalarını
mesajlarla geldiği bir tarihi macera
Dolayısıyla ben Arke tipleri çalışırken
bir yandan Roman yazıyorum ama bir
yandan da bu engin dünyaya dalınca
bayıldım tabi ve esas olarak personanın
bir latincede oyuncunun maskesi anlamına
geldiğini öğrendim yani persona
insanların günlük hayatında dışarıya
yansıttıkları yüzü yani kamusal yüzleri
gerçek kişiliklerin dışında olmak
istedikleri yansıtmak istedikleri
yüzlerin
niye yapıyorlar karşı tarafı etkilemek
için yapıyorlar ve kültürel olarak kabul
edilen makbul olan ne ise biz
personamızda o maskeyi
takın buna uyuma
olabileceği bir alan ise maske ile çok
ciddi özdeşleşmek kendimizi maskeden
ibaret zannederek Onun bir rol olduğunu
unutmak diyor o zamanlar
Peki ben kimliklerimden kısaca
bahsetmiştim
kimliklerimde Aslında tek bir kesişim
noktası var işte bisiklete bilmem ne
işte arkeoloji merakıyla yazarlıkla
pazarlama Aslında bunların hepsi benim
hem çok meraklı ve soru soran bir kişi
olmamda şekillendi hem de kesişim
noktasında insan davranışını anlamaya
çalışan bir birey var diyebilirsiniz ben
çok merak ediyorum insanlar neyi niye
yapıyor Dolayısıyla bugün bana personel
konuşacaksın dediklerine bayılıyordum ve
Yine bir sürü sorular sordum bu sorulara
Benim pek cevabım yok Bu arada sadece
soracağım ve düşünme egzersizi yapacağım
bir çoğunun Cevabı da Bence bunun
bilemiyoruz Ama en azından düşünmek diye
düşünmek egzersizi yapmak bile benim
için çok keyifli bir tecrübe Ben önce
tabi kendime şey sordum yani personel
şart mı yani insanlar bu kadar maske
takarak Yalancı durumuna düşüyorlar
yoksa topluluk içinde yaşamak için
fedakarlık mı yapıyor kendiliğinden
vererek Maske takmak zorunda mı Ya da
ikisi de mi ya da değil mi Dolayısıyla
önce Aklıma
ne yani niye var o zaman
sıklıkla Göbeklitepe seminerleri
veriyorum Aslında bu pazarlama
seminerinde de kullanılabilecek bir
slayt Çünkü çok insana dair bir şey biz
insanların iki tane temel dürtüsü var
bir tanesi üreme ve çoğalma diğeri de
sosyal kabul üremenin altında aşk da var
annelik de var Şefkat de var yani soyun
devamı için ne gerekiyorsa o var
ikincisi de sosyal kabul ise topluluk
içinde kabul görmek ve bir yer edinmekse
o zaman persona ihtiyacımız var diye
düşündüm ben bunu soracağım bilmemekle
beraber Çünkü üremek için de eş
bulmalıyız etkilemeliyiz sosyal kabul
kazanmak için de topluluğ çok
etkilemeyiz Demek ki etkilemek için
kullandığımız maske çok da insani bir
şey olabilir yani hep bir Riyakarlık
yalan ve fedakarlık değil aslında toplu
olmanın birlikte yaşamanı ve insan
olmanın bir gereği olabilir diye
düşündüm çünkü Aslında biz tür olarak
çok vahşi bir türüz çok küçük gruplar
arasında örgütlenebiliyoruz Aslında
sayıda epitopu 150-151 öldürdüğümüz bir
dünyadan geliyoruz ve şeyimizde çok
değişmedi yapımız bir yandan
dünün yabancı kime değer ve bugün
yabancı kime ders sorusunu sorarsak
dünkü yabancı çok net akrabalık bağım
olmayan benim klanımın dışındaki herkes
yabancıdır ve derhal öldürürüm Yani
benim arazime girdiğinde pardon Neye
bakmışsınız dünya yok Oysa bugüne
geldiğimizde yabancı değil dediğim kişi
kim belki devletler açısından düşünelim
vatandaş kaç vatandaş var
Türkan 5 milyon E ben 85 milyon
akrabalık bağımlı olmayan insanlar bir
arada yaşamak zorundayım ve aslına
bakarsanız ilk ilkel dürtülerim de pek o
kadar kalabalıklara alışık değil
Dolayısıyla
düşündükler sonra kavrama acaba değişmiş
midir insanlar kalabalıklaştıkça yani
Biz eskiden kan bağımız olan 20-30
kişiye kendimizi kabul ettirmek
zorundayken şimdi milyonlara geçince
acaba değiştirdi Belki de bilmiyorum
değişmedi yani sayının hiçbir önemi yok
da persona varsa var yani ha ben işte
Amcamın kızının elbisesini kıskanmışım
ama internette her gün bakıp bakıp
farklı farklı kişilerin elbisesini
kıskanıyorum bunu bilmiyorum cevabım
olduğundan değil ama bizim Aslında
personayı Ne zamandan beri var Hep mi
vardır değişti mi sorularının sesli
sorulmuş hali diye düşünebilirsiniz
benim gene aklıma gelen ve koyduğum
slaytlardan biri büyük ihtimalle biz bu
personaya hazırlandık nasıl hazırlandık
Madem dürtülerimiz çok kalabalık gruplar
halinde yaşamaya müsait değil bu kadar
birbirimizi öldürmeden işbirliği yapacak
şekilde nasıl örgütlendik belki
biyolojik bir açıklaması vardır O da
belki insanların beyninin frontal
logo'nun gelişmesidir O ne beyninin en
son gelişen kısmı Evrim ve en son
gelişen bölüm Hatta buna toplu
toplumsallaşma organı diyorlar
beynimizde geliştiği zaman biz ilkel
dürtülerimizi dizginler olduk Yani bir
frenimiz var artık belki de bu fren
sayesinde 10 kişilik gruplardan daha
kolay kalabalıklar haline gelmişizdir
Ama eğer biyoloji nedeniyle kalabalıklar
halinde yaşamaya başlamış olsaydık o
zaman Aslında çok daha erkenden
kalabalık olmamız gerekirdi
O zaman belki de bir kültürel faktör
devreye girdi düşünüyorum ki benim
Göbekli Tepe anlatılarımda çok temel bir
grafik bu Niye Çünkü çok uzun yıllar
milyon yıllar süren bir biyolojik
evreden geçtik Ondan sonra büyük
kırılımımızı yarattığımız kültür
devrimini gerçekleştirdik Ondan sonra
grafik tam anlatmasa bile aslında bu
böyle değil uzaya doğru dimdik çıkan bir
hızda çıkıyor Ne oluyor endüstri devrimi
Sonra da teknoloji devrimini yapıyoruz o
zaman da bu kültürün getirdikleri Belki
bizim personamızın üzerinde etkili veya
personel olduğu gibi duruyor da bizi
zorluyor psikolojik olarak onları
bilemiyorum ama Göbeklitepe niye burada
koydum niye kültür devriminin kalbine
yerleştirdim çünkü
ilk kez bu kadar kalabalık insan
topluluklarının bir araya gelip bu
şekilde yaptığı bir yer yani serbest
gezen küçük kabileler ilk defa bir araya
geliyor bir sebepten birbirlerine
öldürmüyorlar ve orada bir işbirliği
başlatıyorlar bu çok büyük bir dönüşüm
yani Niye bir araya geldiğinde işbirliği
yaptım bugüne kadar göbeklitepe'nin çok
eski olduğunu anıtsal olduğunu tarihi
sıfırdan yazdığını Duyduk ve tarihi niye
sıfırdan yazdı kısmı İşte bizim
hayatımızda Bizi bugüne getiren çok
büyük bir kırılma sebep olduğu için
bebek Tepeli konuşuyoruz Peki bizim
personelamızda o zaman neler olmuş
olabilir kültür bizi nasıl etkiledi
Çünkü biyoloji etkileseydi çok daha
önceden belki kalabalıklaşırdık Bence
Kırılma Noktası Burası belki kültür
devrimidir kültür değerinde göbekli
tepede şölenler yapıldığını biliyoruz
bir sürü hayvan kemikleri bulundu
yenilmiş içilmiş aynı Bugün Urfa'da
yapılan Halil İbrahim sofraları gibi
büyük büyük geniş yemekler yiyor ve
Aslında orada Barış tesis edildiği ile
ilgili planlar arası bir fikir var ama
esas
gen değişik dokunuşunun yapıldığı
söyleniyor yani kız alıp verilmiş
Dolayısıyla yine bir personele ihtiyaç
var herhalde iş bulmak için bir de
üstüne burada Abacı topluluklarının
arasında bir enteresan yapılaşma
başlıyor ne başlıyor bazı arapçalar
heykeltıraşcılar göbeklitepe'yi inşa
etmek için gereken şantiyenin başında
şantiye şefi oluyor yani bir şantiye
şefi aracımız var
bireyken traş avcımız var Belki
kalabalıkları yedirmek içirmek için bir
organizatör avcımız var Bu da eşitlikçi
toplumdan ufak ufak katmanlı topluma ve
hiyerarşik topluma geçişin gözünü
kırpıyor bize değil mi Bugün biz buna
çok alışığız ama o zaman öyle değildi
Demek ki insanların birbirine
personasını yaratmak için ve desteklemek
için belki yavaş yavaş da objeleri
kullanmaya başladılar objeler Aslında
her zaman kullanılıyor değil mi Ama
objelerle ilgili bir hiyerarşik
sisteme hizmet ettiğine dair bir cümle
kurmak istiyorum ve hemen Hiyerarşi
deyince yani göbekli Tepedeki onun
temsil ettiği kültürdeki başlayan bu
katmanlaşma ve Hiyerarşi dünyada hemen
karşınıza bir tane fotoğraf koydum ben
bu kişinin kim olduğunu bilmiyorum
ismini
Ama şöyle bir baktığımda Bir kere bu
kişi erkek bu kişi beyaz bu kişi asker
Amerikalı ve üstün rütbeli Yani bunu
nereden anlıyorum onun yıldızları
olmasından üniformasından artık
bayrağından Aslında hiyerarşinin bayağı
tepesindeki bir kişi ben bu kişiyi
tanımadan bile onunla ilgili bir intiba
edilecek Halim Çünkü hiyerarşik sisteme
geçince kültür devrimi ile birlikte biz
tanımadığımız kişilerle ilgili hızlı
itibar edilme sistemleri geliştirdik
onun paralelinde de bu kişinin
personalasına tıkır tıkır tıkır
objelerle bayraklarla üniformalarla da
okur hale geldik yani Kültür her zaman
güçlü Bu da güçlüğü temsil ediyor ama
Eskiden güçlü nasıl ayırt ediyordu kız
eş seçerken kaslarına bakıyordu Şimdi de
belki biraz daha taşıdığı rütbeleri
orijinallere eşyalara bakıyor olabilir
ki eşyalar bozulur özellikle süslenme
kısmı insanlık kadar eski bütün
mezarlardan çıkıyor ama benim burada
dikkat çekmek istediğim şey biz bu
persona yaratırken Eğer katmanlı bir
topluma geçtiysek eşyaları da büyük bir
ihtimal kullanım alanının fonksiyonunun
ötesinde kullanmaya başladık yani ne
demek istiyorum Tabii ki her zaman vardı
değil mi bu kolyeler boncuklar ama bazı
deniz kabukları belli bir süre sonra
kabile liderinin sembolü oldu yani o
artık deniz kabuğu değil fonksiyon
olarak o başka bir hiyerarşiye işaret
ediyor ve bu da bizim personel aramızdan
birini
hem okuduğumuz hem karşıya gösterdiğimiz
personellerden birinin
temsil eder hale geliyor o yüzden ben
giderek eşyalarla o kadar özdeşleşmiş
olabiliriz ki bizim personelimize hizmet
ettikçe toplum karmaşıklaştıkça eşya
sahibimiz arttı diye düşünüyorum ya da
düşünmek üzere bir fikir üretiyorum
Çünkü bugün çok enteresan bir tez var
çatalhöyük'ten geldi Biz yerleşik hayata
eşyalar için yerleştik diyen var Yani
bizim evimiz vardı İçine eşyayla döşedik
değil o kadar çok eşyamız oldu ki hep ev
yaptık diyor çünkü herhalde artık
eşyalarda bu kadar insan dürtülerine
hizmet eden personanın belki elçisi
oldular kullanım alanlarının dışına
çıktılar Dolayısıyla Aslında ben
gerçekten anlattıklarımın doğru olup
olmadığını bilmiyorum bir düşünce
egzersizi yapıyorum ve diyorum ki
personel Belki de personadır ne işe
yarar bakar ne de kalabalığa bakar ne de
kültür değerlerine bakar Evet kültürle
şekillenir Çünkü neyin makbul olduğunu
kültür iyi güzel de bugün bize fark
etmez ama bana öyle geliyor ki biz
Aslında
teknoloji kızımıza biyolojik olarak
uyamadığımız için kültürde aşırı hızlı
değiştiği için bir göstermek zorunda
olduğumuz personel sayısı çok kırılgan
değişken ve hızlı
bu personel kaç kişiye göstereceğiz Yani
o kadar artmış durumda ki Belki
uzmanların bize personelle ilgili
uyardığı duruma bizi daha çabuk
getiriyor niye sosyal medya Çünkü bu
içerikleri hazırlamak için uğraştığımız
zaman saat o kimliği giymek için
harcanan vakit Herhalde gerçekten ne
olduğumuzdan Biz de belki uzaklaştırıyor
olabilir ve ben de yazar olarak bu
personellere Tabii ki çok kullanıyor her
sona yine personanın arkasındaki ne
bütün yazarlarda bunu kullanıyor Çünkü
bir hikayenin Aslında girişi personelle
başlar Mesela bu benim kahramanım
olsaydı size kullandığı arabadan
fiziksel özelliklerinden mesleğine kadar
anlatarak bir portre çizdim Siz bu
kişiyi çok iyi tanırsınız Ama sonra ne
olurdu Ben ona öyle bir kriz yaratırdım
ki bu personeline arkasında gerçekte ne
vara size göstermek İsterdim ki Kanlı
canlı bir hikaye olsun
ben bu personanın ve yaratılan krizle
onun arkasında ne Var'ı kurcalamanın bir
deneyimini anlatmak istiyorum
romanlarımdan biri aracılığıyla
dedim gibi 7 uyananlar yumdan çok
bahseden bir kitap orada da mitolojiyi
kullanmıştım Kahraman yaratırken Benim
iki tane kadın kahramanım vardı ikisini
de iyi tanıyorsunuz kitapta adları Sedef
ve deniz diye geçiyor ama arka planda
Bunlar Demeter ve Artemis şimdi Demeter
Yani benim Sedef olan kahramanıma denk
gelen esas Arka plandaki tanrıça Yunanlı
bir bereket tanrıçası o kadar kudretli
ki Yani bütün Yunan dünyasında bereketin
sembolü O olmadan Çimenler yeşermez
ağaçlar meyve vermez başaklar büyümez Ve
bu çok iyi bir anne çocuğu için
yapmayacağı şey yok Çok şefkatli ve
çocuğunu canından çok seviyor ve onun
kızı persepole canımdan çok sevdiği kızı
persepoleyi Hades kaçırıyor yeraltı
krallığına Tabii Demeter perişan kızı
kaçırıldığı için
çocuğundan başka bir şey düşünemediği
için bütün yapraklar dökülüyor Kış
geliyor işte başaklar büyümez oluyor
Doğa duruyor ta ki persepole Baharda
tekrar yeryüzüne çıkana kadar Şimdi
benim kahramanım da aynen böyle idi
çukurovalı bir Hanımağa çok varlıklı
bütün işçilerini dert olur Sırf onların
sağlığı için bir bedava ücretsiz sağlık
hizmeti alabildik diye hizmet kuruyor
kendisi bir konakta yaşıyor herkese
yetişiyor bir Hanımağa çok da kuvvetli
bir kadın ama gelelim bu demetlerin
maskesini düşürme işini şimdi demeterin
maskesini düşürmek için ve de sedefin
maskesini düşürmek için ben onların çok
sevdiği kızlarını ve ovalarını karşısına
Tabii ki Bir dişi sinek çıkardım biricik
oğlu var Bu çukurovalı kadının karşısına
bir dişi sinek çıkıyor o zaman oğlunun
etrafında dönen bu kadından hiç
hoşlanmıyor hanıma neden
maskesinin Ardında Aslında amacı iyi bir
annelik olan bir değil ihtiyaç duyulmaya
ihtiyaç duyuluyor öyle
ki güzel bir evlilik yapacak eş adayı
bulsa ondan Çünkü çocuğu ona bağlı olsun
gitmesin istiyor Yani yetişkin olmasın
ayaklarının üstünde durmasın o benim
çocuğum kalsın istiyor Hatta persephone
Hades de aşağı indiğinde Aslında
yün analizi yapanlar onun memnun
olduğunu söylüyorlar Biraz nefes alıyor
yani Yetişkin olduğunu anlıyor kızcağız
Ama bu Demeter bunu kancaları takmış
sedefte oğluna takmış yaşatmıyor
kancaları peşinde çocuğun gelişmesine de
izin vermiyor Yani yok mu böyle
kadınlar değil mi Anadolu'da da var
bizde de var Eşini bile karısına
bırakmayan anneler modeli
şeyin maskesini düşürdüğüm sahne
karşısına bir kahramana çıktığı sahnede
ve o da artemis'te artemis'te Amazon
kadını feminist ve kadın davası için
yıkayacağı kişi yok
II O da tamam Demet'in karşısına bir
ücretsiz doktorluk yapan Hekim olarak
çıkıyor bu Aile Merkezi kurduğu işçileri
için demiştim Sedef için orada çalışan
psikologlardan biri bir kıza taciz
vakasını tespit ediyor hemen Artemis
kılıcı çekiyor yani psikolog Deniz ve
savaş başlıyor Ama bunun da maskesinin
Ardında çok vahşi bir kişi var yani
tamam kadınların davasını peşinde
koşuyor zannediyoruz ama öyle bir
kişilik ki gözü döndüğünde kendini
rahatla görüyorsa bütün şehri kılıçtan
geçiriyor kadın çoluk çocuk demeden çok
uğraştı Dolayısıyla Biz romancıların çok
sevdiği bir konu önce personayı
anlatıp maskenin arkasındaki
kişiliklerin gün yüzüne çıkmasını
sağlarız E tabi kahramanınız Allah için
sonunda dönüşüme uğrar bu Demet abi ama
tanrıçalar öyle kalıyor ama bizim Roman
ları
Dolayısıyla ben sorular sorarak
başlıyorum İşe personelar ve onlar
arkasında ne var merak ediyorum hem
atalarımızdan hem Roman
kahramanlarımızdan hem Kendinizden
gördüğüm kadarıyla Aslında maske sizde
pek olamıyoruz çok insani bir durum ama
günümüzün koşulları kendimizi maskeden
ibaret olmaya biraz fazlaca zorluyor
gibi Bunun sebebi de kültürün maskeyi
çevreleyen kültürün çok hızlı dönüşmesi
ve çok fazla insana kendimizi
personamızı göstermek zorunda kalmamız
diye düşünüyorum hepimiz için de
personadan ibaret olmadığımızı
bildiğimiz Onun bir rol olduğunu idrak
ettiğimiz güzel günler diliyorum ama
maskeli balığımızda eksik olmasın Tabii
hep beraber olmak adına çok teşekkür
ediyorum beni dinlediğiniz için